[Musik]
noch heute leben viele wilde Mustangs in
ihrer natürlichen Umgebung im weiten
Norden
Amerikas doch der immer knapper werdende
Lebensraum hat schwerwiegende
[Musik]
Folgen immer mehr Mustangs werden
eingefangen und in Auffanglager gesperrt
wo sie entweder als Reittiere verkauft
werden oder auf dem Schlachthof
Enden einige Wildpferde schaffen es in
eine Auswahl und nehmen an einem
jährlichen Wettbewerb in Europa teil dem
Mustang Makeover Wettbewerb dabei haben
ausgewählte Pferdetrainer und
Trainerinnen 100 Tage Zeit einen wilden
Mustang aus den Tiefen Nevadas zu zähmen
und beim großen Finale einer
renommierten Jury zu
präsentieren ein Derk TE ilnehmer ist
der abenzeller reitrainer Walter
gegenschatz ja ich meine wenn wir die
Mustangs Fragen drüben wollt ihr ins
Flugzeug steigen wollt ihr darüber
kommen wollt ihr geritten werden dann
sagen die nein wir wollen in der prerie
sein oder wir wollen das ganze Land
haben wir wollen die Natur und so
[Musik]
weiter aber jetzt haben wir uns
entschieden diese Mustangs hier rüber zu
nehmen wir haben n entschieden diese
Mustangs zu
reiten und jetzt ist es glaube ich an
uns Ihnen zu vermitteln dass sie am
Schluss dieser Ausbildung oder an am
Ende jeder Session sagen können hm
vielleicht war es doch gar nicht so eine
schlechte
Idee dann mest du quasi noch einmal
unterschreiben also wir haben den uns
angeschaut und haben jetzt nichts
gesehen dass der Grund oder Stelle hat
oder ja Bein F oder ja
ja ja dann glaube ich dir das wfagt Word
ob will dem Event teil ne bin ichmer
nicht ganz sicher will es gibt
unterschiedliche meinige zu so Events
und ich hab mit de mit Meer Frau
Unterhalt oder wir hier und her
diskutiert und sind den zum Schluss kom
wir machen da mit nutze die Plattform
zum aufzeigigen was man kann erreichen
oder was ja was möglich ist wenn man
Bezier zum R er stell
[Musik]
stellt mein Name ist Walter gegeschatz B
parell F sterninruktor B da auf dem Hof
aufgewachsen meine älter h milchf
Betrieb und W der Hof über Noa
umgestellt in ein
[Musik]
pferdeusbildigsbetrieb
bewirtschaften
produzieren für R
[Musik]
selber auf Betrieb je nachdem wie viel
Rind ausbildig sind zwis 20 und 25
Tier Natural Horsemanship für mich ein
Umgang mit dem R auf natürliche
also was ist natürlich für es
[Musik]
R der erste Tag der Challenge Walter
gegenschatz bringt seinen wilden Mustang
aus Nevada auf seinen Reiterhof im
aben also
apparatmchen
so willkommen im
aberazellerland ich glaube die sind
hauptsächlich am Kopf berührt wordde hab
man mal am Hals strrich vielleicht
irgendwie so ganz klar aber viel meh
glaube ich
nicht find faszinierend wie sie quasi im
Moment sind sie sie sind nicht in der
Vergangenheit oder in der Zukunft wie
wie sie Sachen machen wo wo für den
Moment für Sie absolut logisch und und
sinnvoll sind ob jetzt mehr denk ja da
macht Sinn oder nicht spielt keine Rolle
sondern sie denken ja da mus wir jetzt
zum Überleben macht wir da
Punkt gut
wirk ganz
Z aber das
trügt das
dücht hier auf seinem Reiterhof im
Appenzell trainiert Walter gegenschatz
alle seine Pferde mit der sogenannten
Natural Horsemanship Technik eine
Technik die sich mit dem Wesen der
Pferde auseinandersetzt und die
Verbindung zwischen Tier und Mensch in
den Vordergrund
stellt Natural Horsemanship das Wort mit
Bindestrich schrieben also hab Hor da
ist Ross man das ist der Mensch und man
ship das symbolisch als Schiff für
gemeinsame Reis also jetzt horsem ship
jetzt natural V her da heißt natürliche
Umgang zwischen Mensch schip die
gemeinsam Reise auf natürliche Art und
wies
ein natürlicher Umgang mit R ist für
mich wenn man aufs gegenüber also da
heißt auf Bedürfnis vom vom rossig wenn
man lernt Verst wenn es fluchtier
funktioniert walter hat mit dieser
Technik schon viele Pferde trainiert und
ist damit auch in offiziellen
springreitturnieren
erfolgreich
[Musik]
mit dem
MA reagiert
[Musik]
sch
genau das B honorier Rohan so heißt der
wilde Mustang aus Nevada ist jetzt schon
Tage
imenell bish g es nur Interaktion Z wter
und dass man nicht einfach nur ihr geh
sondern dass Interaktion
ist he
Boy reagiert
sch also bis jetzt hab wir nur so Sache
gemacht
nur Kontakt Aufgen Form v
er gibt so viel wie er gibt oder er kann
bestimmen wie wieter sot wie viel dass
er sich getraut und so wiiter und wenn
man s die körpersprachet den sehen wir
immer noch dass er mit relativ langem
Hals das Gras da holt und frisst also
sch immer ist im Kopf h ist immer noch
Bereitschaft für Rückzug oder für
weg und
berüh das nur berührt und wenn wir L hat
persönliche Zone und die ist natürlich
jetzt noch relativ groß
und persönliche Zone oder man könnte dem
a sagen man könnte dir das nennen
Energiefeld also Energiefeld
undis und wenn jetzt
Gang er getraut sich H wunderbar aber
wenn jetzt i an Gang und n seh h das
bereits wirkig also die Energiefelder
treffen sich und nieus da heiß nam ist
kurz ich kan nicht berühren und jetzt
brachen wir
verlänger mal l ob da
langet ob ich mit dem und jetzt W wir
dass Strich
aber ich nicht direkt Strich da heißt
ich berühre sie Energiefeld oder S
persönlich Zone und dann fangen
wir Ausdruck Gesichtsausdruck beobachten
jawohl und dann zeigt man da wie groß
das s s persönlich Zone
ist
got jetzt brachen
und
Z jawohl wenn ins Gesicht l sehen jawohl
wo ist sin
Bereich
gut
immer da mal
ziemlich mal ob ich
bebe jawohl bis er sich entspannt der
orientiert sich anderem das das Zeichen
von entspann
wieder er der Welt er macht der
Kontakt kann ich Kontakt machen
jawoh eruck g wieder
weg
fur genau se schon lang und der Mensch
reagiert nicht oder nimm
[Musik]
oder verürze
Hand und sogar noch wieder zurück ja ja
Limit schafft das jawohl sehr gut D sich
nicht wegrei also nicht ganz
umrei am
halsich entspannen Schleck wieder Lippe
ruhige entspannte Session gute eruck
glaub das L so
[Musik]
gut gelernt hat Walter diese Natural
Horsemanship Technik in Amerika wo er
mehrere Jahre bei seinem Lehrer und
Mentor Pat perelli gelebt und gearbeitet
hat im
1997 h parellis erst mal
geseh ist der pferdemess off in St ges
Video gelaufen und
ichbelaufen mehr oder weniger und
stblber hat das gesehen und bin beruck g
was die Person auf dem Video gemacht h
mit mit ihrem Ross oder und denkt wow so
W die auch
eine bin no eine vier Jahr auf Amerika
gegangen also ichad vom Pat zum zu auf
tren
[Musik]
Gründer vor dem ganze System der Pat the
Horseman ursprünglich ja nicht ein
Cowboy oder w sich nicht als Cowboy
bezeichnen sondern ein horse man ein
[Musik]
Pferdemensch
Linda der Lehrer oder der Psycholog
woit auf Gefühl oder auf Bedürfnis V
ander Mensch K
[Musik]
oder einzigar Parelli System ist sich
Lernsystem also da dass es vermittelbar
ist dass es l len wenn man
nicht im pferdestallft
Welt der P ist für mir ein großer Mentor
oder das Vorbild und in den jah wo ich
den bin hab ich natürlich sehr viel zit
oder Möglichkeit zum
beobachte zum einen im Umgang mit Ross
aber zum anderen auch wenn er
unterrichtet und jetzt wenn ich da
schwitz oder wenn ich unterrichte den
bra ich natürlich ganz viel redewendige
W auchwendet und ja denk vi V mE aber
ursprünglich ist natürlich vom P
[Musik]
über die Jahre hat Walter den Hof zu
einer modernen und pferdegerechten
Reitsportanlage ausgebaut gen
morgen er hat mehrere Mitarbeiterinnen
darunter auch seine Frau Barbara und
seine Eltern und
[Musik]
helf
vi und
Nin noch
ST helfen und
St dieoralp
im
nähstoffreiches nor ale Futterreserven
also für die verschiedenen Pferde auf
dem Hof Jungpferde ausbildungspferde
aber auch Pferde mit
Verhaltensproblemen ihre Betreuung ist
die finanzielle Grundlage für Walter und
sein
Team doch das war nicht immer so denn
ursprünglich waren seine Eltern
[Musik]
Milchbauern das ich sind Betrieb und wir
d einfach unterstütz wo man könt und
helfen was man könt aber mir haben Freud
wir so jetzt aufom Hof wiedergang ist
das H nicht m mit K obwohl du überzüugte
bur milchbur aber das istinit ist nicht
alle zit es ist g so wie es jetzt
ist
le zu hab wir auch
immer immer
freut auch
wenn da aber den sie mir alle
vierind und D freut so sind gewachsen
das ist
gut na ja
was deine Hand uns in Gnaden zugewand
wir danken
Diren so wün
dan
also der Wal ja immer gem W W und
irgendwann haben wiram gesag wenn sich
gagit
ergtauf Mais will einfach so Freud und
den
ichel Nachbardorf und somit ist den der
mit dem Traktor und dem fcherhker und
natür mit dem Walter das Rö hol so ist
den sie sehr und da ist duind der Walter
also ich glaube dass das mer der Umgang
mit der Ross sehr viel kolfe hat auch im
Umgang mit Menschen will der
bezirksgrundprinzipie sind ja genau die
gleiche oder es ist es mit und
fürreinand es ist es investiere i bez W
trinier wo der Umgang mit andere
Menschen vereifach es ist es Verst vom
Gegenüber oder wie wie funktioniert wie
Ticket m gegenüber damit ich Verst warum
dass er sich so oder anders
verhaltet mittlerweile ist Rohan schon
zwei Wochen auf dem Reiterhof im
abenzell Walter und er konnten sich
schon ein wenig
anfreunden so bereits der er Druck von
mir ist eigentlich sie D sehr überleit
ist und sehr schnell lernt also sehr
denkend unterwegs
[Musik]
ist
dasü
cool ja ja noch cool der Mensch ist
nicht schlecht in dem System in ist
natürlich eine extreme
Persönlichkeitsentwicklung also der
pferdeteil würde ich sagen ganzen
untergeordnet od kine Teil es geht viel
viel mehr um die eigene persönliche
Entwicklung wer wä die wer bin ich oder
wir bin ich wir wirk wir wir auf M ein
influs H also was wir beflus min
Persönlichkeit m
gegenüber und jetzt man da mal B
[Musik]
erkundeuskundchaft
es ist selbst refflektieren oder es ist
es merk oder wüssen ja was strahle den N
wenn ich für das bewusst sie erlangt kan
oder dann kann ich das ja auch veränder
od sag war mal ich muss bisschen langsam
oder
ne ich muss bisschen mehr auftreten oder
ich wirke halt
immer Schü oder ich wirke halt sehr
dominant wenn ich weiß W ich wirke also
mich selber reflektier denn kann ich ja
m besser verstahen warum das M gegenüber
so oder anders sich
verhaltenepsis z all
z
jawoh seh da
buchmuskel
gut doch ein Publikum mit die mal zu dem
Tor über laufen und ganz natürlich me
beobachtet s
Reaktionen stieben man wieder verdauen
jawoh gut mal
HÜP jetzt machen wir das so lang bis er
sich kann entspannen jetzt machen wir
noch mal ein klein
Versuch und zwar mit grü aber he s g
wieder B Weg D man schönen Abstand h und
dann Kön mal
applaudieren bisschen
länger und
nochmal der
but
wunderbar also mein jetzt fangises
Publikum g jetzt mal DAV in faldorf W Z
mä aber ich glaube vussetz sind da dass
das ein erfolgricher Tag kann werden
oder dass er nicht überfordert ist mit
mit der Situation
den
bis zum großen mustangfale bleiben noch
83 Tage Walter nützt die Zeit um mit
Rohan eine Pferdeshow in feralddorf zu
besuchen dort möchte er seine ersten
Fortschritte mit dem Mustang vor einem
Publikum
präsentieren wenn ich das einfach für m
mache ja klar dann könnte das hätte sich
freut und das war
schön aber zum eine bin ich
Naturell mitteil oder steile und oder
wenn irgend Erfahrung machenis lern den
treib mich sofort umum und verzähle da
wier da ist dois Naturell und die Glaube
oder sie w do cool oder wenn wenn andere
Menschen Kön von MM wssen profitieren
oder von dem Gedanken und wenn andere R
Kön
profitieren
ich mchte meinen pferd
lernen dass es den Menschen akzeptieren
kann zuerst als Freund der zweite
Schritt ist dann akzeptiere den Menschen
als Vorbild oder als Alpha als Lieder
der dritte Schritt ist dann das
Akzeptieren des
Sattels und der vierte Schritt ist das
Reiters Versuche in der
Geschwindigkeit in der ich glaube ihn
konfrontieren zu
können
vorzugehen zum ersten Mal überhaupt
versucht Walter an dieser Show seinem
Mustang Rohan auf den Rücken zu
steigen gar nicht so einfach denn
Wildpferde sind als Fluchttiere sehr
sensibel gerade am Rücken in freier
Wildbahn müssen sie sich uation schützen
z.B wenn sie von Pumas oder Wölfen
angegriffen werden das Rohan Walter
ansatzweise aufsteigen lässt zeugt von
großem
Vertrauen nicht
he
scharfchüs wir sind jetzt hier ein
bisschen im klinch weil wenn man drauf
klettern
kann dann g sehr gut und gerne die
Möglichkeit dass man dann
behauptet das wäre
gefaked also der ist schon
geritten aber der ist noch nicht
geritten so weit hinten hat ihn bestimmt
noch niemand
berührt ich glaube das lassen wir so
h
Hammer
Pony gut
ich glaube ihr dürft
applaudieren würde sagen wir nehmen ih
mal da dieses Mustang schnürli Weg
so der Wechsel von Mustang zu
Reitpferd
[Musik]
ne aha du dentink gut
festlichat oder lern mir meh mir me
respektieren jawoh in dem Moment W ich
Gefühl setzt sich damit auseinand ja W
wir jetzt len in Ruhe also gib ne den
Druck
weg F zu
verschieden zu verschieden
Objekt er komm auf die Situationen zu
auf die verschiedene ausforderunge und
SEAG okay was machen wir mit dem was
machen wir der Situation und ne W das
Problem ne mit dem kan und die andere
richtig also
problemü W immer noch lös sucht nicht
noch
[Musik]
Problem du
bist du bist
parat
[Musik]
Z und es macht kein
Unterschied es ist schon verruckt dass
mit die R da über die ganze See flügt
oder da V Amerika DAH und für so
verstaltig es g ganz sicher in Europa
Knur wo man Kön R oder wo man R oder wo
man so veral K machen der Mustang
oder
einfach Magie und zücht Drums größere
Publikum und jetzt ist das natürlich
gerheit
zum Botschaft zmittel will man es
größeres Publikum hat wir auch Botschaft
dass die Situation vor den amerikanische
Mustangs nicht die beste ich meine die H
für die Anzahl R wo den sind h Z wenig
Platz drum fangen und in
Auffangstation zu Tausenden R wo einfach
dahin vegetieren also das ist auch das
ist kein würdige Situation das ist
furchtbare Situation und können auf das
aufmerksam machen
finde ich glaub schon ein wichtiger
Punkt wie viel dass man denn noch einem
Schluss veränder weiß sie nicht oder da
das LI sicher in höher politische gräie
aber ja man muss das Probieren und undis
machen und auf der Punkt also auf die
Situation
hwiesen
[Musik]
สย ja
wahnsinnon ja h am
[Musik]
vne
ja irgend
arrosäßig so
oder oder ob
muskulär
zhetechnisch ich ein Moment auf
[Musik]
der ja das
wei
[Musik]
da ist die rechte S oder vor ist perfekt
oderes und da ganz Spitzel Weg ja ja
machen
zündk den zündig Weg
oder ja für
uns
Option uns geht ja nur drum kann man
weitermachen mit dem Tier oder nicht und
das ist ja klar nicht und was sie dann
machen was müssen Sie entscheiden
hufglenk schon ein sehr erhebliches
Problem Schmerz ist das nicht unbedingt
ich glaub ist Druck der ist nicht l h
aber der hat gich oder koordinationell
ja na das ist gut oder
sch Diagnose oder de
Leid ja ja cool
eigentlich nach Einschätzung des ti
Arztes muss sich Rohan seine Verletzung
am Hufgelenk bereits in der Wildnis
zugezogen haben er wird zwar wieder
normal laufen können aber seine
reitkarriere ist vorbei ja genau und was
passiert jetzt mit dir
kolg ich glaube so wie das jetzt
klingt wir du V da
weit ich glaube nicht dass du da noch
irgend große
Aktion große Show mach aber das ist ja
ziemlich gich
mein ja jetzt W wir Hal L mit der
Organisation M L ob das auch mi ist das
abentür auf M beendet ist
fertig wenn wir jetzt die ganze 100 Tag
zu
verfüg den H wir wahrscheinlich sch
relativ gut ausbildet zeige da ist ganz
klar schade das ist ganz klar
[Musik]
schad war schon wier trocken
da wenn du zu ihm auf die Weide gehst
einfach vielleicht ein paar Tipps auch
für bei dir zu Hause oder so sch das wen
siehst du jetzt z.B ach schon dass du
diese ich sage jeweils das sind sowieso
Kreise einer persönlichen Zone dass du
die respektierst
gut
morgen
wunderbar g
[Musik]
Bo ja
alterkeptiker
okay ich haben wir noch nie überle zum F
mE nicht wirklich vussetzig W das
vielleicht in Deutschland h oder wo
wirklich auf größer weit mit größerer
Gruppe
[Musik]
K wenn no gesund W ganzes
interessant gut aber man muss auch
bewusst se was man W machen mit
Ross ja
[Musik]
ja dank einer partchaft hat ran einen
Weideplatz in Deutschland bekommen wo er
von nun an trotz seiner Verletzung am
vorderen Hufgelenk ein würdiges Leben
haben
wird super dann viel
Spaß er ist schon zielstrebig er weiß
was er will das stärche vom Walter das
ist imm glich was die andere l git wenn
andere B am me sind ich no trainier
nacher me
also er ist nicht so
welmtig er weiß was er will und ich im
auchich was die andere
sag
positiveell ist nicht jeder Tag gich
undm habf wo groß sind was wirklich
schwierig machen zum
positivellig
aber es wie soll ich sagen ich glaube am
Schluss STZ und fallt vieles mit die
Wurzel oder mit den Grundlage oder auf W
ist dies Leben aufbauen was gibt der
halt was gibt der Zuversicht was gibt
der Sicherheit in schwierigen Momenten
hilft ihm ganz sicher auch sein starker
Glaube seine Verbundenheit mit Gott das
war auch eine Sache wo mich von Anfang
an sehr fasziniert hat weil ich kannte
das so nicht so auch wirklich einen
gelebten Glauben und das war sehr sehr
faszinierend und ein bisschen muss man
das auch üben das positiv bleiben und
positiv denken und ein bisschen muss es
einem auch gegeben sein ich als alter
Skeptiker weiß es ist manchmal nicht
ganz
[Musik]
einfach bis zum großen Finale in aen in
Deutschland verbleiben noch etwas mehr
als d Wochen die Organisation des
Mustang Makeover Wettbewerbs hat für
Walter gegenschatz einen neuen Mustang
gefunden das Tier wurde zuvor von einem
anderen Teilnehmer betreut der sein
Training aber unverhofft abbrechen
musste damit bleibt Walter also
weiterhin im Rennen diesmal mit der
mustangstute belessa willkommen
[Musik]
im hab entschieden mit der belesser wier
Z machen will ich natürlich dieforder
oder ja das so Sache Reiz mich natürlich
und jetzt okay du Woche das RA ja h
wahscheinlichch nicht allzu viel gemacht
oder aber ihr ges dass man dazu mal in
New Mexico ich meine wir sind die wilder
Mustangs aus der prie die sindmer noch
vier Tag s die
gritte in Show oder oder vor Publikum
aber wir sind gessen und da würde wohl
heißen dass sie in D Woche auch noch ein
das andere herbringen s könen mit mit
der
belesser da jetzt neues genau eine
andere Situation sie wird sich das Herz
fassen jawohl gefühlsmäßig für Sie wir
mehr
Pullover ist einfach ein Ball auf der
rucke machen wir so ganz viel am Zügel
wenn sie mitkt gut
[Musik]
wunderbar
und dann ist es endlich soweit Walter
fährt mit seiner mustangstute belessa
nach Aachen ans große Mustang Makeover
[Musik]
Finale der Wettbewerb zieht jedes Jahr
viele Zuschauer an und ist für
Pferdekenner ein bedeutender Anlass ja a
nicht wahscheinlich für Pferde l
ungefähr wie wimelon für Tennisfans od
also ist schon no speziell wenn man da
ST oder D od ich in a Grit ja jetzt
nicht im großen pris oder nicht im
Springen aber ja Mustang Makeover sch
nicht
schlecht der Wettbewerb bietet vor allem
eins Show und Spektakel Bier und
Bratwürste schnell wird klar hier steht
nicht nur das Pferd im Mittelpunkt man
muss gewisses Maß
Publikum mein s got wirtschaftlich nicht
ganz klar oder und denn das Publikum
sind nicht alles pferdeel oder extrem
Pferde interessiert die L oder da heißt
sie sind interessiert andere Schau mit
Spektakel oder mit lter Musik und dies
und das oder und jetzt der Spagat findet
Bedürfnis befriediger vom Publikum aber
ohne dass man R über irgendeine Klippe
stoßt und und Prinzip überbeut wirft ist
sicher nicht immer ganz
[Musik]
einfach längst nicht alle teilnehmenden
arbeiten nach der natural horsemhip
Methode wie Walter
gegenschatz während des Wettbewerbs
können hier ganz unterschiedliche
Techniken beobachtet werden jetzt zeigt
sich welches Trainingssystem am
effektivsten
[Applaus]
ist die nächsten beiden die
reinkommen gegenschatz mit Stiefels
[Applaus]
[Musik]
bel erstreckt sich über drei Tage mit
mehreren Parcours und Aufgaben am Ende
entscheidet eine internationale Jury
über die beste
[Musik]
Darbietung
in der Wildnis meiden Mustangs enge und
dunkle Höhlen ganz instinktiv es könnten
sich Raubtiere darin befinden und es
gibt keine
Fluchtwege das bel Angst überwinden kann
und in den Anhänger steigt zeugt vom
Vertrauen dass sie in der nur kurzen
Zeit zu Walter aufbauen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
konnte
das ist einach nicht so mi Ding oder da
irgendwie der große Zirkus zu machen und
ja da fühlt man sichm bisschen komisch
halt aber ja n da muss einfach
mitspielen in dem in dem Zirkus und und
ja wenn es muss se dann muss es halt se
ich persönlich B lieber ich zeig also ja
was mir wichtig ist oder min Wert auf
und und da ist jetzt vielleicht das
große
Spektakel m Ziel Challenge ist das G
erfahr also das aus R DAV profitiert das
ist mal wichtiger als große Show oder
Resultat
wenn das Hand in Hand Gott also wenn di
eine positive Erfahrung sammel und dur g
Resultate über will eure bezieh auf dem
Niveau ist mein den super
[Musik]
cool
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also mE Gedanke zum n am Seil machen
sondern frei ist ja das Mus vielleicht
noch
offensichtlich
lchtigkeit antworte also wie wenig ist
das M schneller langsam richtig
se den auch bindig also m blibt n mehr
nur will se dran sondern es ist der
freie
[Musik]
Willen Schluss ist es ja Ross egal was
ein Rang das man hat viel wichtiger ist
derfahr und und V dem her muss ich sagen
man kann nicht Fred se oder ist es ja
gut Gefühl will ich
habzwungen s irgendwo drüber druckt oder
mehemt als W ja was sie h könen geht im
[Musik]
Moment
Rang 6 für Walter gegenschatz und bessa
dafür dass sie nur drei Wochen gemeinsam
trainieren konnten sicherlich ein
beachtliches
[Musik]
Ergebnis
also natürlich sehr vieles über R
gelernt aber genauso viel glaub auch
über Menschen oder über mich selber
auch das selbst refflektiere sich selber
seeh und ist ein wichtigge Punkt ich
glaube immer dass man sich selber nicht
so wichtig n also sehen wir ja denn dass
das eigene Ich sehr zentral ist und und
eigentlich alles ausfüllt und dann h wir
für die andere oder
anders h gar kein Platz und je mehr das
jetzt auch mit dem Ross oder mit der
zusammenabit mit L oder der bezieh
oder Platz hab fürs gegenüber also sag
aus der Sicht vom R betrachte oder was S
den Bedürfniss oder was du um leben vom
Gegenüber vereinfachen ich glaub das ist
ein sehr zentraler Punkt im der
Philosophie oder ja in ja
[Musik]
Lebensphilosophie ein gutes Jahr später
ist Walter in Deutschland wo er einen
alten Freund besucht der hier einen
schönen Platz auf der Weide gefunden hat
und seinen Ruhestand genießt sie sind da
hinten auf der Weide sie sind da hinten
auf der Weide genau okay genießen ihr
Leben so guck da siehst du sie schon die
drei die vier na ja schau da hinten
genau und dann mega ist ja immer mit
seinen Kollegen zusammen immer der ist
ja gut integriert und es ist die Ruh die
Runde Seele ist das in unserer Herde ist
ein ganz toller Bub cool darf ich mal
reingehen und schau bitte bitte bin mal
gespannt
na
mal
cool W jetzt Frieden auf der weit sind
nein so schön bäum Wind frisches Gras
Wasser Kollege aber will
man hey boy
[Musik]
und DAH schon oder Natur also Musang
immer noch in klar ist jetzt nicht
einfach so blauäugig
und und ist eine andere Situation oder
auf der offene
weit schon Moment her gemt miteinand
aber jetzt mal oder ob man da machen ob
sich
getraut
ja
Tag ja ja ja
bra nach Mustang ja
ja na aber
gut du da
super wie
got ja sine Auge entspannen sich schon h
mach du wieder erinneren
Kollege
h W da cool zit na vielleichtich nicht
so schlecht g bist zu Amerika im
flügerestiegen und auf
[Musik]
Europa